les députés ont adopté un amendement
visant à taxer les super dividendes
versées par les grandes entreprises
c'est amendement a été présenté contre
la vie du gouvernement par le président
du groupe démocrate Jean-Paul Mattei qui
fait pourtant partie de la majorité
réforme réformes c'est bon plus les
points de fourbe l'opposition à applaudi
cette taxe sera de 35% sur les
dividendes qui dépassent de 20% la
moyenne de ce verset au cours des cinq
dernières années
je ne fais du Grand et Petit on est tous
amis C'est la fête
franchement oui bah oui la vérité autour
de 50000 euros par mois je pense que tu
es
mille euros par mois
à partir de combien on est riche
moi je pense que
vendeur de parfum c'est désormais comme
ça que se présente Elon Musk depuis hier
sur Twitter après les voitures ou les
fusées le milliardaire pointe le bout de
son nez dans le commerce de fragrance
son parfum décrit comme le meilleur sur
Terre en toute modestie s'appelle don't
hair traduisez poils brûlé une drôle de
senteur qui attire les acheteurs
puisqu’en moins de 24 heures 20 000
flacons ce sont déjà écoulés la vraie
richesse c'est surtout je vous le dis je
veux dire une banalité mais c'est la
santé
[Applaudissements]
et les fleurs aussi c'est la fête
à noter la flambée du prix de l'huile de
tournesol dans l'Ukraine et le premier
producteur hausse également du prix des
carottes du fait de la sécheresse mais
aussi du dentifrice du steak haché du
café ou des spaghettis monsieur
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai l'impression de me réveiller
d'un rêve assez agréable je suis au
milieu d'une salle il y a trois caméras
avec un mec que j'ai jamais vu qui me
met des baffes
pour faire plaisir
c'est un nouveau rapport alarmant pour
la biodiversité selon le fond mondial
pour la nature près de 70% des animaux
sauvages ont disparu en 50 ans la
destruction des habitats naturels en
particulier pour développer
l'agriculture reste la cause principale
de cette disparition
chaque courrier étiquette ou document
administratif peut les mettre sur la
piste du responsable comme ses factures
trouvées dans les déchets
c'est un indice c'est un indice oui
c'est un indice c'est même une preuve de
dépôt sauvage pourquoi ces papiers sont
là et pas dans la poubelle ces agents de
la Ville de Pontoise dans le Val-d'Oise
sont assermentées pour sanctionner les
propriétaires de ces ordures musk à ne
pas confondre avec l'odeur musc demande
même à ses followers d'acheter son
parfum pour que lui puisse acheter
Twitter sous le choc sous le choc
carrément mais pourquoi je suis sous le
choc parce que c'est moche quoi
en
[Musique]
chatons
les ghetto twins s'amusent à reproduire
le jeu vidéo GTA dans la rue du virtuel
au réel ces trois artistes de
Saint-Nazaire utilisent la loi
Atlantique comme terrain de jeu entre
Nantes et La Baule avec tous les codes
de GTA dans le gestuelle des personnages
bluffantes
leurs nombreuses vidéos cumulent des
millions de vues de quoi patienter en
attendant GTA 6
voilà pour le programme de Tesla ils ont
que des prénoms les mecs Samuel Étienne
Olivier et voilà comme peinture en série
d'ailleurs merci Thomas
il y a des hommes politiques aussi
c'est quoi la normalité les
neurotypiques nous sommes des
neurotypiques après tout est-ce que
c'est si on viable il y en a pas ça
n'existe pas c'est normalité elle a été
créée par cette société par ce monde qui
pensait que la manière d'agir du commun
des mortels était celle qu'il fallait
suivre en fait c'est à dire que vous ça
tous d'accord pour dire que d'un
individu à l'autre je parle pas des gens
qui vont encore pinailler en disant oui
mais moi j'agis pas comme ça ben
peut-être que toi tu es à part il faut
peut-être réfléchir
mon cher Daniel mon cher Josselin dans
un instant c'est la finale j'aimerais
remercier Mélanie Page d'avrette
troisième manche
attendez parce que moi maintenant j'ai
tout rangé